[موسيقى]
نعم انسحب الاحتلال بشكل كامل من محيط
مخيم طولكرم في هذه الاثناء بعد ان خلف
دمار كبير وواسع في البنا التحتيه داخل
هذا المخيم وقام
بتجريف بشكل كبير في الطرق الرئيسيه هنا
نرصد حاله لربما تشاهدون حاله الدمار التي
تسود في هذه المنطقه وعند المدخل الرئيسي
للمخيم في هذه اللحظات بعد ان انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال بشكل كامل من محيط هذا المخيم
قوات الاحتلال دفعت بعشرات الاليات
العسكريه وبرفق جرافه من طراز دي 9 وجراف
الدواليب نحو المخيم قامت بفتح بعض
المداخل التي وضعت عليها المقاومه سواتر
ترابيه ومن ثم بدات ال انفجارات تتوانى
واحده تلو الاخرى نرصد في هذه الصوره
الدمار الواسع الذي خلفه الاحتلال في
البنى التحتيه من شبكات الصرف الصحي
وشبكات المياه في هذه اللحظات وايضا خروج
المواطنين بعد ان حوصروا لعده ساعات على
وقع هذه هذه العمليه
العسكريه في محيط المخيم وداخل بعض
الطرقات الرئيسيه داخل هذا المخيم قبل لحظ
ظات قليله فقط خرجت جرافه الدي ناين وجراف
الدواليب برفقه عشرات الاليات العسكريه من
محيط المخيم باتجاه بوابه 104 او ما تسمى
بتسني عوز الى الغرب من المدينه بعد عمليه
عسكريه تواصلت لاكثر من 12 ساعه في مدينه
طول كرم ب مخيمها مخيم نور شمس ومخيم طول
كرم قوات الاحتلال ايضا في مخيم نور شمس
قامت بتدمير البنه تحتيه اعتقالات واسعه
تم رصد ما يزيد عن 100 فلسطيني تم احتجازه
في مركز اعده الاحتلال للتحقيق الميداني
افرج عن بعضهم فيما قام الاحتلال باعتقال
البعض الاخر وتحويله لمراكز التحقيق في
هذه اللحظات هنا في مخيم طول كرم منذ
ساعات الليل وحتى اخر اليه عسكريه قبل
قليل وتم رصدها اثناء خروجها ايه تم القاء
عبوه ناسفه باتجاه هذه الجرافه الانفجارات
في مخيم طولكرم والاشتباكات منذ ساعات
الليل لم تهدا حتى يعني ساعات الصباح وحتى
هذه اللحظه تم تدمير واعطا اليه عسكريه
وهنا نشاهد ايضا اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
جديده تاتي الى هذه الى المخيم على ما
يبدو في هذه اللحظات نعم اذا اليه عسكريه
في هذه الاثناء تاتي الى مخيم كما تشاهدون
نعم اذا هجوم اليه عسكريه جديده الى مخيم
طول كرم في هذه اللحظات واطلاق للنار نعم
اذا الان تبادل لاطلاق النار نعم الان
تبادل لاطلاق النار في عند المدخل الرئيسي
لمخيم طول كرم فيم